[Musique]
oui ici à viterbe tous les gosses
arrivent à l'école avec le sourire et
surtout en voisin mais que font ceux qui
dans les bois le brouillard et bientôt
le froid sont à 5 10 km de l'école la
plus proche
le ramasseur dès le petit matin on pense
à elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on entre dans le bois à vide encore
enfin premier arrêt
[Musique]
bah ouais confère à le voilà oui
mesdemoiselles votre taxi est avancé
[Musique]
oh il faut connaître le chemin
oh mais ici il faut des numéros d'appel
alors allons-nous vous poussez pas la
pagaille bat fils tu sois bâtisse plus
moi quelle est la la plus jeune
dis donc tu viens l'école depuis combien
de jours tu sais plus tu sais pas compté
jusqu'à 2 tu viens depuis deux jours un
de deux jours oui à bâle va faire des
progrès là le temps qu elle est la
doyenne la doyenne assieds-toi la guyane
alors ça fait combien de temps que tu
prends le cas quatre ans et le doyen
will elle doit y aller tu prends en
charge du domaine tant que moi aussi je
prends trop sinon 3 à 3 ans olala métaux
a indiqué qu est ce que tu veux faire
plus tard
je sais pas hommage sur des colliers est
autorisé aux écoliers seulement damiatte
terminus nos amis rejoignez copains déjà
arrivé
où étais tu toi et nous les grands et
faire aller à saint paul cap de joux aux
marchés traditionnels
gk
où sont les orients à la partie fashion
bel air à bon comment vous aviez l'école
vous de votre temps à pied y avait les
sommes en jeu dit les 20 km 3 km oui et
vous mangez au bras le corps le poids ni
on le rappelle sa lumière
elle était pleine hier soir le racing a
tout à l'heure à 5 heures
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le clair de lune mais c'est
bien le retour au bercail il en moque
d'eux
qui sont partis aux champignons
[Musique]
au revoir s'il dit
selvi 3 en deux jours d'école
ce chemin des écoliers peut être pour
vous une belle promenade
la voici après la mort entre viterbe et
saint-paul damiatte la capelle et retour
[Musique]